in this blender tutorial I'm going to
show you how to quickly set up an
infinite background that has a curve so
all the Shadows Fall Off very softly
this is great for setting up Studio
Lighting in blender and if you don't
want to just have it on one side you can
make it a corner shape so it's kind of
like a photo swoop in a corner the first
thing we want to do is go ahead and move
our Cube up so I'm going to press G then
Z then one and that just moves it up to
the top then I can press shift a to make
a new mesh and I'm going to make a plane
I'll press s to scale and I'll scale
this up
it's not really important how big this
is but I'm going to scale it just a
little larger then we can press tab to
go to edit mode I can select this vertex
and if I right click I can click bevel
vertices
so now I can bevel the vertices you see
how I'm pulling it in and when I click
at about this range I can come down to
the lower right to get the options then
I can increase the segments so you want
a good amount of segments so you know 10
segments is probably a good amount and
then you can also vary the width if you
weren't happy with your original
decision so you want something kind of
like this
then you can go ahead and switch to Edge
mode by pressing two and I can click
here once hold Ctrl then click here once
now I can press e and then Z to lock to
the z-axis and go straight up
now I'm still in Edge mode so once again
I can click here hold Ctrl click here
this is picking the shortest path so it
selects these all automatically then I
can right click or press Ctrl or command
B and I can right click bevel edges and
then it will start to Bevel those edges
as I reach down
and now I have a nice bevel here and of
course you can change the number of
segments that you want if you want it to
be a bit smoother I'm going to go up to
15 and now I have this nice photo swoop
that I can use for lighting and then if
I tab back to object mode I can right
click and shade smooth so it looks very
smooth and I can also press s and I can
scale this up and generally when you're
shooting something with smooth lighting
like this you want the object to be far
away so I can press G then shift Z to
lock to the X and Y axes and then now I
have this light and everything set up so
I can switch to the scene lighting and
then I can move this light
by pressing G then shift Z to move it
over here and then I can press
alt or option D to duplicate then press
shift Z and I'll move this one right
over here
and so now you can see that I'm getting
these nice soft Shadows now in Eevee you
need to increase the the size and power
of those lights a lot but if I was going
to switch my renderer to Cycles here
you'll notice that I'm getting that nice
fall off alph into the distance and of
course I can change the intensity of
that light if I change that to something
like 5000
then if I move the lights back by
pressing G then shift Z I can move this
light very far away and then I can do
the same with this one and I can press G
shift Z and move it away then I can
shift-click both of them press G and z
and move them up so as the lights get
farther away
all the shadows will become softer and
nice and then if I
tab into the view camera
you can see that I have these nice
shadows and then if I go ahead and look
at View and I lock my camera to The View
you can see here I can get a nice Studio
render with a nice infinite background
and I can keep moving those lights
farther away and change the intensity to
get the lighting setup I need
let's see how that looks in Eevee so
here in Eevee we also get that nice
soft Shadow Fall Off and it's a really
easy way to go ahead and make a studio
lighting setup so this is how you do it
with
two walls you can also easily do this
with a single plane so if I go shift a
and I bring in another mesh plane
and then I can press G and then shift Z
to move this plane over here press s to
scale
then if I tab into edit mode and I still
have Edge mode selected or press 2 then
I can go ahead and just bevel this Edge
right here after I extrude it so I can
press e then Z extrude up and then I
click this Edge right click bevel edges
and then I can increase the width of
that bevel so now I have a traditional
single photo sweep so sometimes this is
the proper setup with a single sweep
like this and other times it's better to
have that surround feeling so no matter
what you're doing you can quickly make
infinite smooth backgrounds in blender
with just a few bevels and extrudes
happy 3D modeling